KORY JEFFREY:
Welcome, everybody.
We are on site at Founder
World in San Francisco.
I am joined in the studio
right now by Bill Santana,
CEO of Knightscope.
Thank you for joining us, Bill.
WILLIAM SANTANA LI:
Glad to be here.
KORY JEFFREY: Awesome.
So you have probably the most
visible product here today.
And it's because it's
all around the building
and at the front door.
Can you tell us a little
bit about what that is?
WILLIAM SANTANA LI: Sure.
Knightscope's developing
technology in the long term
to be able to predict
and prevent crime.
We have five foot tall, three
foot wide, 300 pound machines
roaming around here that
generate 90 terabytes of data
per machine per annum.
And we use that data
for two things--
for the obvious monitoring
and surveillance, and also
to influence our autonomous
navigation stack.
One big step to get to
that long term vision
is to do anomaly
detection, and looking
at what is, quote, unquote,
"normal" in an environment.
And giving a private security
guard or a law enforcement
officer-- let's think of
it as smart eyes and ears
for them to do their
jobs more effectively.
KORY JEFFREY: Awesome.
So if we think about that,
you have your bots that
go around kind of key areas.
WILLIAM SANTANA
LI: Autonomously.
KORY JEFFREY: Yeah,
autonomously, right.
And so this, then, feeds
into either a system that you
guys run, or into
an internal security
system that a company
would already run?
WILLIAM SANTANA LI: Right.
So most large corporations,
which are our customers,
would have their own
security operations center.
We would actually
download a Chrome browser
and be able to log
into what we call
the KSOC, or the Knightscope
Security Operations Center.
It's a browser-based
user interface
that allows our clients to
interface with the machines.
Humans aren't all that
great at reviewing raw data,
but they're really
good at event analysis.
So we have the machines do
the monotonous, computational,
heavy, and sometimes
dangerous work,
and then let the humans to
do the "strategic" work.
KORY JEFFREY: Sure.
And so how precise has it been
in actually false positives
or actually putting
things up that
are of interest to the humans
for the event analysis?
WILLIAM SANTANA LI:
So yeah, there's
a lot of different
opportunities there.
Some of it is just plain,
simple sensor analysis.
If you've got hyperlocal
temperature, humidity, CO2,
and pressure, you can do some
interesting things with that.
Or, once you start
gathering all this data,
if we're doing optical character
recognition on license plates
and a client asks
for, you know what?
We need a parking meter.
Let me know if any car has been
parked here more than 24 hours,
or 48 hours, or 72 hours.
And you can just
keep sending alerts
based on that simple rationale.
Or you can look at parking
utilization for a retailer.
We know the number
of parking spaces.
We operate mostly outdoors.
Any number of parking spaces.
We know the number of vehicles
we've seen over the last hour.
We can give you
utilization rates.
Or simply at a mall, between
10:00 PM and probably 6:00 AM,
there should be no one there.
If we see a person, raise your
hand and let the guard know.
KORY JEFFREY: Awesome.
So you've been at this
for about two years now,
I believe, just over.
So where is it today?
Like obviously, there's bots out
there right now doing the job.
Are these out in
the marketplace?
Are you selling them right now?
WILLIAM SANTANA LI: Yeah.
So we're actually
deploying technology now
with our customers.
We've signed our
first few agreements.
We've got about 104 customers
on a very long wait list.
And one of the reasons
we're here at Founder World
is F50 was very kind to twice
invest in our financing.
So we were oversubscribed
on our seed round.
We're oversubscribed
on our series
A. And looks like we're going to
be oversubscribed on our Series
B.
And wanted to share
with the founders
here that, as I
mentioned this morning,
don't ever let an
investor tell you no.
I mean, the first year was very
hard, because what we're doing
is a complete outlier.
Who would wake up one
morning and say, hey,
let's take robotics plus
autonomous technology, sensors,
analytics and big data, and
combine the whole thing.
And we're going to go after
a space that isn't really
an investment thesis
for most funds, right?
No one's off disrupting the
offline security industry,
right?
That's not a--
KORY JEFFREY: Sure.
Yeah, I've never seen that.
WILLIAM SANTANA LI: So it
was kind of very difficult.
But my team and I, we
stuck with our guns.
And everyone told us that this
would be, one, impossible,
it would take $50 million
to build the first one,
it's never going to work.
And we're pretty happy that
we've made a lot of progress
in a short period of time.
Listen, we've still
got a lot of work
to do to get to
our grand vision.
But if you look at crime,
the problem is really severe.
Part of the theme
for the conference
is let's start
thinking big again.
We've been thinking big
for the last two years.
And if you look at crime,
it's actually a $1 trillion
negative economic impact
annually on the US alone.
You add up all the murders,
ambulances, lawyers,
and everything else, it's a
hidden tax, and a very large
one that we all pay every year.
But if you think about
innovation, over the last 100
years, there's been
what innovation
in the security space?
I think there's been a taser,
a bulletproof vest, and maybe
a camera.
That's the extent.
And having been
born in New York,
I'm pretty upset over what
happened after 9/11 or at 9/11.
We just as a country
haven't really
been investing in the space,
other than cybersecurity.
And I think there's
a huge opportunity.
If you look at the Department
of Defense's budget,
we have maybe now significantly
larger than $600 billion a year
spent by the
Department of Defense
to give our troops every level
of capability you might ever
imagine.
And I'm good with that.
What I question is 2 million
law enforcement professionals
and private security guards
get up every morning,
are willing to take a bullet
for you and your family,
and the level of technology
that we provide to them
as a country is certainly
beneath the dignity
of our nation.
And I think it's high time that
entrepreneurs demand that we
make some serious change.
Because let's say we
hit our grand vision.
We cut crime by 50%.
What does that do to society?
Talk to me about housing prices.
Talk to me about
insurance rates,
the viability of
someone's business,
the safety of your family.
Everything changes.
And that is a worthy
goal to work on.
KORY JEFFREY: So that's
awesome, and you're clearly
very passionate about it.
What's the inspiration?
Is there like a
coalescing moment for you
that kind of sent
you down this path?
WILLIAM SANTANA LI:
Two or three things.
One, as I already
mentioned, 9/11.
The Sandy Hook shooting
a couple of years
ago was-- so 26
innocent people get
shot in an elementary school.
I don't believe the founders
of our country expected
that, when you got up every
morning, that you went
to school, you went to a movie
theater, you went to the mall,
you went to the
library, that you'd
have a risk of getting shot.
That's not acceptable.
And somehow as a society,
we get up every morning,
turn on the news, and we
see something horrific.
And we move on.
It's not OK.
And so that was part of it.
The other part of it,
if you look globally,
we have 7-plus billion
people on this planet.
We're going to grow
to 9 billion people.
Having traveled around the world
like most people, trust me,
I don't think the law
enforcement or the security
apparatus is going to scale.
We need a better
way to do things.
And we need to do
them more efficiently.
And we should be able to
leverage the technologies that
exist and develop
some new ones on top
of all the great foundations
that Silicon Valley
has provided us.
KORY JEFFREY: That's a
really interesting point.
So here at Founder
World today, there's
all sorts of different
technologies spending all sorts
of different verticals.
Is there something that
you see for your space,
besides obviously
drones, that would
be a next wave or another
really good addition in order
of innovating that space?
So something like virtual
reality or machine
learning or--
WILLIAM SANTANA
LI: Yeah, there's
something that we--
a couple of things.
One is the machine you
see outside is probably
the smallest one
we'll be building.
So there's different
form factors,
depending on what our
clients might need.
So certainly iterating on the
form factor is an opportunity.
The user interface can
be very interesting.
What you saw outside
in terms of the KSOC
is basically a two
dimensional view of life.
There's no reason
that could not be
an immersive opportunity
for a crime analyst
to understand what's happening.
And I think there's also
an opportunity a little
bit further down the road
to crowdsource security.
Think about what happened after
the Boston Marathon bombing.
Everyone was actually
trying to help--
uploading stuff on
YouTube, tweeting,
sending all sorts of stuff.
But if you're the
crime analyst, exactly
like, where am I
supposed to look?
And if you ask the
FBI, how long did
it take you to get the data
from Boston to DC to analyze,
depending on who you believe,
it was about two weeks.
That can't be happening.
And so that user interface
should be an opportunity
to combine a lot of the
gaming technologies,
some of the augmented
and virtual reality
stuff that's happening
in the long term
to give a crime analyst a
real, fulfilling and real time,
immersive environment to figure
out what the heck is going on
and how to deploy resources.
KORY JEFFREY:
That's really cool.
Thank you very much
for joining me.
WILLIAM SANTANA LI:
Appreciate you having me.
KORY JEFFREY: Thank you
guys for joining us.
I'm Kory and we are on site at
Founder World in San Francisco.
[MUSIC PLAYING]